Jérôme Durin bonsoir c'est pas une
soirée de Joyeuse pour vous on entend
pas mal de villes qui basculent à droite
dans ce département de la Saône-et-Loire
c'est vrai effectivement c'est une très
mauvaise soirée pour le Parti socialiste
et pour la gauche en Saône-et-Loire avec
un phénomène national et une
amplification du des résultats du
premier tour et puis de mauvaises
nouvelles qui sont liées aussi à des
divisions locales
ou la gauche résiste ce n'est pas le
Parti socialiste qui gagne je pense à
Bourbon-Lancy mais à une candidate
divers gauche quels enseignements vous
en tirer notamment
de prix m'a
diversité politique à gauche et que ceux
qui avaient l'étiquette politique du
parti socialiste ont été durement
sanctionnés donc ça appelle évidemment
une réorientation politique nationale on
voit qu'il y a un message très fort qui
a été adressé par les électeurs donc je
crois qu'il faut évidemment
armaniments il faut un nouveau casting
et puis il faudrait orientation
politique il faut entendre le message
que les électeurs ont fait passer ce
soir
avec par endroits Jérôme Durin sur croit
une difficulté à s'entendre avec
d'autres composantes de la gauche
exemple à Cluny par exemple ou le total
des voies de gauche ce soir est
supérieur à celui du nouveau maire mais
là vous avez pas réussi à vous entendre
il y a deux endroits qui sont
symptomatiques de ce que vous dites
c'est effectivement en cuni et louant ou
le total gauche nous permettait en
théorie arithmétiquement de l'emporter
et effectivement on voit à la fin une
victoire de la droite donc la division
nous coûte très cher dans un contexte où
il fallait savoir s'unir et porter nos
couleurs ensemble donc c'est un message
qu'il va falloir qu'on travaille et sur
lequel il va falloir méditer dans les
jours à venir